well I don't want to say that because
and that means I'm going to we're all in
a long march towards doubt
hi I'm Sam Stryker and I'm curly and
worth a film Independent Spirit Awards
in Santa Monica where we're gonna have
celebrities if they've had any
encounters with spirits
we've been gravely disappointed we
thought there were going to be actual
spirits at the award today well that's
why you're here to protect us do you
believe in ghosts we'll get right to it
yeah who doesn't
I'm dead inside I'm a total skeptic
although what sometimes I'm freaked out
I believe it goes yeah have you ever had
a paranormal experience but I'm really
hopeful hundreds thousands probably I
mean I had moments where I've been
scared where I'm like I'm not going down
that hallway because I just feel it's
not a good thing to do right now I'll do
it tomorrow
something kept changing the TV channel
and I wasn't touching the remote Netflix
and chill but with like a goat there was
no chill chill chill and I was walking
past and like in the corner of my face
like I saw something like hanging with
SIA hanging from the chandelier or oh my
god oh my god Kate Blanchet just said we
look fabulous
who would you come back and home
you hold are you yeah I would want to
hunt a descendant of mine that I haven't
met yet
probably my kids too like a happy heart
yeah I'd happy haunt them I wouldn't
haunt but I would follow my exes to see
what they were up to I would hunt
Disneyland so I could just go on all the
rides and I get to skip all the line no
I don't need to die to haunt Donald
Trump I'd like to haunt Donald Trump for
the rest of his life all right guys that
was the Independent Spirit Awards we
didn't see any ghosts but we saw plenty
of stars and Kate Blanchette said we
look fabulous so she met me I think